I'm back from California and my first
act go see Conan I got nothing Conan the
Barbarian or Conan the Barbarian
whatever I'm gonna call it conan-kun
ends pretty straightforward this is
really evil guy doing evil guy things
and Conan's gonna stop them that
description more coherent than the
actual movie I don't know what it is
about this movie it seems like a really
shitty video game movie that never
happened to be specific it's the Zelda
movie that never happened I'm glad it
didn't there's a really evil ambitious
guy who's really nobody in the world and
he makes an impression on this really
fearless kid when he's really young
flash forward years later the really
ambitious guys now a really ambitious
warlord he's more powerful and all that
and the fearless Kid is now a fearless
man and Ganondorf over here is looking
for this really peer chick so he can
like do his evil things and rule the
world
I'm telling you guys I gamer wrote this
movie who doesn't know how to write
movies I mean the plot and pacing is
just all over the place it does what I
hate I've bitched about it before is
that every scene in this movie is an
isolated scene that doesn't lead into
the next scene I mean they'll be in a
town next scene they're in captivity
next scene they're on a boat next scene
they're in the woods as uh as for Kuna
and the character I thought he was
alright but I don't know that Conan's
actually a barbarian I really don't I
have seen the actor who plays Conan in a
barbarian role he was called Drogo in
Game of Thrones that was a barbarian
seeing him like this like alright well
you're just likeable guy that they want
to be a barbarian but you're not a
barbarian
if Conan the Barbarian strolled into my
territory and civilization 5 would be
like you know what you're alright you're
a barbarian and I'm not gonna wipe you
out in fact I'm not gonna go into the
options and turn barbarians off cuz I
like you I don't know and the chick in
this movie is like the dumbest character
ever I always liked the actress I don't
know why maybe it's because she's hot
but she's always in these shitty movies
and I know she's better than that I hope
all right here it is one of the many
scenes I have a problem with in this
movie Conan the Barbarian goes onto this
Beach you know they're docked at a cliff
or something she chases after him next
scene they start making out and they're
in this random cabin with a convenient
pile of hay on the ground that they can
bang on where this cabin come from
seriously and after that this woman is
the most wanted woman on earth by the
bad guys if the bad guys get her it's
done it's over she does the thing where
she sneaks out of the cabin without
waking him up runs on the beach next
scene she's in the middle of the woods
not on the beach woods but like you know
Nottingham Forest woods and of course
she gets captured what you think was
gonna happen I I don't even know about
the N fire I mean earthquakes are
happening Conan's throwing down with
Ganondorf and then earthquakes aren't
happy
being the place isn't crumbling and then
it is again it's not ever play smoking
fire with cards you know like smoke
smoke fire
it's like someone did that to the
storyboard of Conan the Barbarian
they're like all right we're gonna play
the movie out as it is on the ground
that's not a joke I think that actually
happened is Conan the Barbarian dog [ __ ]
yeah it is why does sound like Mark
Wahlberg Jason and the 3d is converted
3d I heard it was actually 3d that they
shot it in 3d but I was watching I was
like no it's not I looked into it sure
enough it is not reason 151 it's flash
to the Titans part 2 so don't see it why
would you see the help see Fright Night
seek Apes in any case if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more why did I
look like Nicolas Cage when I did that